hey I'm here to remind you that your
potential is Limitless you are capable
of achieving greatness but it all starts
with one thing belief believing in
yourself is the first step towards
success you see your environment might
be tough your circumstances might be
challenging but remember it's not about
where you come from it's about the
courage you have to persist and
persevere it's about the audacity to
dream big and the determination to make
those dreams a reality don't let the
fear of failure stop you every time you
fall you learn you grow and you become a
better version of yourself so I urge you
to take that first step today start that
business write that book create that
product do whatever it is that sets your
soul on fire because you have One Life
to Live and it's your duty to make
account so believe in yourself take
action and let's make a difference
together because your belief matters